voisins autour ils savent pas mon cas
mais puisque
il ne rentre pas là on n'a pas
d'histoire elle le témoignage et
attraits d'un film de chris burton n ya
pas de toilettes
colette bana est l'exemple même des
personnes qui pouvaient jusqu'ici
bénéficié d'un dispositif de
défiscalisation social aujourd'hui
menacé il a conduit artisans du bâtiment
membres associatifs bénéficiaires et
personnalités politiques dans la rue on
trouve ça inadmissible et révoltant
voilà alors c'est pour ça que je me
montre solidaire aujourd'hui les faux
sont déjà là et les fonds vont repartir
simplement parce qu'ils ont voté une loi
dans notre dos donc on manifeste on va
déposer une motion colette ban est l'une
des dernières bénéficiaires du
dispositif
son dossier a été validée in extremis
après vingt ans passés dans une maison
insalubre il séduire c'est dur par
moments s'habituer et d'autres moments
en inde révolte on baisse les bras et
puis après le lendemain on essaie de
survivre mais c'est une lutte incessante
le principe est simple recueillir des
fonds auprès d'investisseurs privés pour
réhabiliter les logements de personnes
dans le besoin
ces investisseurs bénéficient en échange
de réductions d'impôts cette année on a
eu 366 demande
on aurait dû les satisfaire tout mais
elle a déjà on a une soixantaine de
dossiers qu'on sait qu'on ne pourra pas
faire parce que ben
on arrête de recevoir des sous on refuse
de l'argent et on n'en renvoient et à ce
jour on doit être à peu près à 4
millions d'euros refusée en cause
l'article de loi permettant la mise en
place du dispositif
aujourd'hui il est menacé par la loi de
finances 2010 9 en marche martinique
soutient pourtant le mouvement en ce
moment notre présidente est à paris et
qu'elle est partie avec plusieurs
dossiers et je sais qu'elle va avoir le
ministère pour défendre son dossier sur
le plan humain que je vous ai dit le
plan économique parce que c'est très
important de le savoir qu'il ya des
milliers des centaines et des centaines
d'emplois qui seront qui sorte qu'ils
sont en danger
oui
la mesure est potentiellement lourde de
conséquences pour une île déjà fortement
impacté par la problématique de
l'habitat insalubre
[Musique]